[Music]
hi i'm christine co-owner and
self-taught baker at creme caramel la
and today i'm going to show you how to
take a traditional filipino dessert and
turn it to one of our best sellers at
our store at cran caramel la we are a
filipino dessert bakery we make creme
caramels bread puddings custard pies
cheesecakes quiches but most of all we
make custard dreams and today i'm going
to show you how to make ube upside down
pie and it all happened because of an
accident i don't know how many times
you've been in a kitchen where realized
oh no i forgot to set the timer and
basically turned a whole day's work into
crap but i made a graham cracker crust
threw it on there and it ended up being
our best seller at our store today
that's what we're gonna make ube ups and
down pie so let's bring my traditions to
your table our first step is to make the
custard so we're gonna get started with
two eggs and we're going to separate the
yolks from the whites after i crack them
i like to use my hands it does get a
little slimy typically in lucha blonde
it's purely egg yolks but our version
has egg whites to make it a little
silkier and creamier you're probably
wondering wait a minute i've made this
before and it's not called leche flan
it's probably called creme caramel which
is the name of our company but it also
could be called caramel pudding or
purine or even creme catalan those are
all basically the same custard base so
custard is basically anything with eggs
or milk you can even make a savory
custard like a quiche but our version is
sweet and our version has tinned milk so
that's what makes it implicitly
lechaflon the filipino version next i'm
going to add the single egg
you want to make sure it's fully
incorporated next we're going to add six
tablespoons of granulated sugar into
the egg mixture
and then now we're going to whisk it all
together after our sugar and our eggs
are well mixed we're going to put in 18
ounces of tinned evaporated milk in the
philippines fresh milk isn't as
available it's a hot country so
using evaporated milk is much better
since it's shelf stable and you don't
have to worry about spoiled milk and
next we're going to add sweetened
condensed milk and you're only using
half a cup of this condensed milk and
you want to make sure you use a really
good spatula to kind of get all those
little bits out there's a word in
filipino language called scion basically
it's like oh what a waste what a pity
and you don't want to waste it if
there's one thing that we do at our
store we're really good about making
sure that we have every little bit used
so we're done with the custard but what
sets ours apart is that we add ube to it
if you don't know what ube is it is a
party in your mouth ube is a purple yam
from the philippines specifically
indigenous to the philippines the ube
flavor profile is very similar to almost
vanilla and coconut we can debate ube
all day i mean people say ube's tarot no
it's not ube is a purple potato no it's
not everyone thinks ube tastes different
what do you guys think comment below you
can source this from your local filipino
grocery stores but if you don't have one
near you you can always go online and
purchase it there so i'm going to add
one tablespoon of ube flavoring into
this beautiful custard
look at that
purple goodness vibrant royal purple
color we're not using powders or actual
ube root because it's going to ruin the
texture and we want to be able to stay
true to that texture of flan as being
creamy and silky and really good mouth
feel now that we've finished whisking
this beautiful purple custard we're
going to strain it it's actually one of
the biggest complaints about custard
people don't like eggy custard or has
like texture of eggs as you can see here
all these little eggy bits are left
behind and they're no longer going to
interfere with your beautiful silky
custard and we're going to put the ube
custard first you don't want purple mess
all over just inside of that pie pan
we are going to scrape every little bit
don't want cyan
you want to use every little bit and
you're probably wondering why our pie
dish is in the roasting pan and the
reason why is because we're going to
slow and low cook this we're going to
add a water bath at the bottom basically
it's going to make the custard cook
evenly we're going to fill up the hot
water halfway up the pan as best as you
can estimate you definitely don't want
it close to the lip of the pie pan
because it'll spill inside once you're
transporting this into the oven we
already have a start with the hot water
going into the roasting pan i like to
add
a cover on top of the pan to create
steam so again we want consistent
custard because like a true lucha flan
you want to make sure that it's
consistent throughout and if this didn't
have the foil on top it'll make a little
crust and that's not very good when it
comes to the final product we want to
make a crust not this kind of crust so
i'm going to put this in the oven for 45
minutes at 350 degrees and then after 45
minutes i'm going to remove the foil and
turn it around and bake it for another
10 to 15 minutes and here is the little
purple beauty you just took this out of
the oven so how do you know that it's
completely set if you do a little jiggle
you'll see that it has a slight jiggle
so we're gonna have a chill overnight in
the refrigerator and i'll see in the
morning
good morning
i am wearing the same thing and that's
okay please forgive it we are ready for
the next part which is our ube
upside-down pie graham cracker crust the
reason why we call it ube ups and down
pie is because we have the crust on top
and the crust came about because i made
a mistake and i wanted to save it the
whole thing of scion so we're going to
measure out three and a half ounces of
graham cracker crumbs so now we're gonna
add brown sugar the brown sugar provides
a little molasses type of caramel leaf
sugar next i'm gonna add some greek
yogurt whole milk yogurt again you don't
want to waste some scraping every little
bit out i grabbed some graham cracker
crumbs and i had greek yogurt and brown
sugar so i just mixed it all together
and i'm like this tastes fine this
tastes good and it's sold out it sold
out that following weekend and i'm like
oh my gosh we have a new product don't
be afraid of your mistakes your mistakes
can always be made to something else to
be honest to make a really consistent
crumb i like using my hand so i'm gonna
get in there and kind of crumble it it's
like playing in sand except delicious
delicious sand if you crush it in your
hands it kind of has a little shape but
then you can easily break it down that's
the right amount of moisture so now
we're going to add our crusty crust onto
the ube custard and then push it all the
way to the side so you cover the crust
or you can be a little delicate i'm
going to be a little fancy into a little
circle after you smooth out the crust
we're going to add some granulated sugar
very light sprinkling not super heavy
just enough so that it lightly dusts the
top of the crust after we sprinkle the
sugar we're going to lay the surface of
the crust and not everyone has a torch
at home and that's completely fine we're
going to stick this into the broiler for
one to two minutes to the broiler
we are done so we have this nice smoky
finish on top i'm going to add a little
purple sugar for a little juice the
reason why we put this on is because we
have other upside-down pies so this is
the indicator for us that is our number
one dessert at our store ube upside
amsterdam pie purple yam custard topped
with the brulee graham cracker greek
yogurt crust i'm ready to sample this i
like to put it in a container that you
can see the purple goodness
i'm planning myself on the back for
making this like oh yeah this is so
delicious the ube custard has that
vanilla e slash coconutty earthy type of
flavor married with the creaminess of
the custard and then as a bonus you get
a crumbly crust anyone can make this you
can make this with your kids you can
make it with your friends you get two
things in one delicious food and an
instagramable pick and that's how you
turn a traditional filipino dish into an
ube upside down pie we welcome you to
come by prem kimmel la try our ube
upside down pie in person pair it with
one of our ube horchatas thanks for
joining me as i bring my traditions to
your table
oh yes
[Music]
so
[Music]
you